hello everyone welcome to today's live
keynote presentation pandemic tracking
contagions from cholera to Ebola and
beyond I am Judy O'Rourke of lab rats
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event labrinth calm is the leading
scientific social networking site and we
are proud to bring you this interactive
web seminar for more information visit
us at lab roots com here's how this
presentation works we want to hear from
you questions comments and even answers
can be submitted via the green Q&A
button at the lower left of your screen
will try to get to everyone but if not
you'll be sure to follow up with you by
e-mail you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you can't hear or see this
presentation properly let us know by
clicking on the support button at the
top right or the Q&A button in the lower
left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Sonia Schott Sonia Shah
is a science journalist and a
prize-winning author her writing on
science politics and human rights has
appeared in The New York Times The Wall
Street Journal Foreign Affairs
Scientific American and elsewhere her
work has been featured on radio lab
fresh air and Ted or her talk titled
three reasons we still haven't gotten
rid of malaria has been viewed by more
than 1 million people around the world
her 2010 book the fever which was called
a tour de force history of malaria by
the New York Times rollicking my time
and brilliant by The Wall Street Journal
was long listed for the Royal Society's
Linton prize her new book pandemic
tracking contagions from cholera to
Ebola and beyond is forthcoming from
Sarah crichton books for our straus and
giroux in February 2016 I will now turn
it over to Sonya Shaw
hi so over the past 50 years over 300
new infectious diseases have either
newly emerged or re-emerged into new
territory where they've never been seen
before we have new kinds of influenzas
novel kinds of coronaviruses
mosquito-borne diseases like West Nile
and dengue and eat and others like Ebola
that are coming up in places they've
never been seen before and so it's sort
of hard to escape the feeling that we
are in store for a pandemic of some kind
that is an epidemic of disease that pops
up in one part of the world and spreads
like a wave across global populations
and continents now this isn't just the
opinion of the worried well it's also
the opinion of experts in the field in a
recent survey of epidemiologists ninety
percent said that a pandemic that would
sicken a billion people kill 165 million
and cost the global economy three
trillion dollars would occur sometime in
the next two generations so of course
now the million-dollar question is which
pathogen will do this and of course
there are a lot of potential candidates
we have 150,000 species of bacteria a
million viruses that can affect mammals
and that's just the ones we know about
so it's impossible to know which one of
these would cause the next pandemic but
what I've spent the last five years
trying to understand as a journalist is
how this process occurs because
historically only very few pathogens
have been able to cause pandemics we've
had your sania pestis which causes
bubonic plague influenza which causes
flu pandemics variola which caused
smallpox pandemics of the past HIV still
causing the ongoing AIDS pandemic and
the fifth one is the one that interests
me the most and that's cholera it's
caused by a bacteria called
vibrio cholerae and it interests me in
part because it's extremely deadly it
kills about fifty percent of the people
who are infected with it if they're not
treated rapidly but more than that it's
one of the most successful of the
pandemic causing pathogens caller has
caused seven pandemics so far and the
last one is still ongoing to this day
and it's latest beachhead is in Haiti
just 400 miles off the coast of Florida
now today we think of cholera as a poor
person's disease and that is true now
but it wasn't always true so when caller
first emerged in the 19th century when
it was an emerging disease it hit some
of the most prosperous technically
advanced cities in the world cities like
New York which suffered a massive
epidemic of cholera in 1832 that's
what's pictured here in the map and that
was just the first of many so it had
repeated epidemics like this as cholera
spread like a wave across the globe and
it wasn't just New York City was also
Paris and London and Hamburg and
thousands and thousands of people died
in these epidemics but they weren't only
just deadly they were also very socially
disruptive and this is sort of a
hallmark of new diseases because people
don't understand where they come from or
why they've suddenly emerged and how
they spread people start blaming each
other and in the cut in the 19th century
people blame the cholera epidemics first
in 1830s they blamed him on the Irish
immigrants in the 1840s they blamed the
cholera on Muslims by the 1890s they are
blaming them on the Eastern Europeans
and this wasn't just sort of verbal
harassment and social exclusion it was
actually violent in one particularly
gruesome example that was only recently
uncovered actually in 2009 right outside
of Philadelphia a mass grave was
excavated and this was in fact what had
happened is Irish immigrants had come
over in 1830s
to build that stretch of railway track
and there was a cholera outbreak the
local people decided that it was the
fault of the Irish immigrants and they
quarantined the valley where they were
living and then came back and secretly
massacred them and buried them in this
mass grave that was only recently
excavated and that's when they found
their smashed skulls as pictured in the
slide there but it wasn't only
immigrants who were victims of this
scapegoating a lot of times it was
healthcare workers which is you know
particularly difficult given that these
clinicians were often the people who
might have been best posed to help
contain these outbursts of disease so
there was frequent cholera riots this
was a common form of social unrest in
the 19th century doctors and other
clinicians were stoned in the street
they were accused of causing caller on
purpose in order to dissect people's
bodies and frequently mobs would form
around cholera quarantine hospitals and
burn them down there was several that
were actually burnt down so so the
question I wanted to answer is what are
the conditions under which these
pandemics pandemics like this can occur
and of course we know that there has to
be an introduction of a new pathogen
right that's part of it but what I found
in looking at the history of collar in
the 19th century is that you know that's
not sufficient there also is you know
the several other conditions that have
to be met so obviously any pathogen
that's going to cause a pandemic has to
become widely disseminated and of course
that means that something or someone has
to carry them because these are microbes
with no independent locomotion so
dissemination is obviously a important
condition to be met for pandemics also
there always is some kind of
amplification some situation where these
pathogens are able to replicate wildly
and thus adapt and evolve to spread
better to Cosmo disease obviously there
has to be sufficient transmission
opportunities you know even the most
horribly variant pathogen
it doesn't encounter the behaviors that
will allow it to spread from one victim
to the next is virtually harmless so
that's obviously an important condition
and finally to cause a pandemic these
pathogens really need to be able to
circumvent our defenses because we don't
just take this lying down we come up
with political defense's medical
defenses etc so all of these conditions
have to be met in order for pandemics to
a car and this is these are these are
exactly the conditions that were created
again and again in the 19th century to
cause these repeated pandemics of
Cholera no collar started out very
placidly it actually is a bacteria that
lives in a scene it's a marine bacteria
it's a normal inhabitant of coastal
waters and estuaries around the world it
likes sort of brackish water so half
fresh have salty and particularly fond
of warm water so places like the cinder
buns which is pictured here it's a giant
wetlands and South Asia it's where all
the major rivers of South Asia drain
into the Bay of Bengal um this is really
great environment for this marine
bacteria Vibrio cholerae and for
thousands of years probably it lived in
that water without encountering a human
being or causing any kind of disease in
people at all because of course people
didn't live in places like the Thunder
buns they're very low-lying they are
tidally flooded twice a day they're
covered in mangrove swamps there's
actually crocodiles or tigers or
cyclones so for probably most of human
history people didn't live in places
like the sunderbans that were rich in
this marine bacterium course that
changed during the 19th century British
took over bengal and they decided to cut
down the Sunderbans and turn them into
rice fields so over the course of the
19th century ninety percent of the
Sunderbans was settled and so quite
suddenly people were having novel
intimate contact with this bacterial
rich water
and vibrio cholerae was able to adapt to
the human body with all of these
repeated exposures and inside the human
body of course this bacteria is not
nearly as Placid as it is in the marine
environment an environment actually it
helps recycle nutrients and so it's
useful ecologically in human body when
the bacteria is lining a person's gut an
infected person it sort of reverses the
normal functioning of that organ so
instead of replenishing the tissues of
fluids the caller infected gut actually
extracts fluids from the body and expels
them people who are infected with
cholera can actually lose up to 15
liters of fluid every day and that's
actually what kills you is this rapid
desiccation you die of dehydration and
when people come in and of course is
incredibly contagious because all of the
stool and vomit that comes out of a
collar infected patient is highly
contagious if you get even microscopic
amounts on your hands or in your food or
water you'll get sick with cholera as
well potentially and since it is a
marine bacteria what would happen is
people get sick and their stool would
enter into the drinking water supply
where the bacteria can persist and
replicate over time so this first
outbreak with this new pathogen began in
1817 in the Sunderbans and started to
spread out of South Asia into Russia and
into the cities of the old world but of
course to cause a pandemic it would have
to conquer global populations have to
cross the Atlantic and get to the new
world as well and before the 19th
century that wasn't so easy it took
about eight weeks to get across the
Atlantic Ocean it was something that was
only attempted sporadically and once you
got over to North America of course
there weren't as many roads or highways
or anything like that there were
navigable rivers but they weren't
connected because they had big mountain
ranges in between them so the the
knurled at least north North American
part was fairly impenetrable
to a marine bacteria like cholera but of
course that changed really rapidly in
1820s starting in the 1820s exactly when
collar started to emerge we we started
using clipper ships those would go
across the Atlantic in a matter of days
and they would do it twice a week and we
built canals and the canals cut right
through all those mountains connecting
all of the waterways so that a watery
bacteria a light color could wash right
into the interior of North America and
into the rest of the new world so this
was a great dissemination strategy for
cholera it worked really well with
bringing color infected people and the
bacteria into the interior of North
America and of course North America as
with Europe was rapidly urbanizing at
this time so this created wonderful
amplification opportunities for the
bacteria over the course of the 1840s
about a million people arrived in New
York City alone and this was of course
the age of you know the new newly
industrializing city's new factories
people were abandoning their farms to
come for these new factory jobs in the
cities of course there was no suburbs
and sprawl and all that people had to
live right near work or the possibility
of work so on a tiny little island like
Manhattan things got very very crowded
quickly in the most crowded parts in
19th century Manhattan in fact there's
about 77,000 people crammed into every
square kilometer that's six times more
crowded than modern-day Tokyo for
example and it's not about a thousand
times more crowded than anyone had ever
lived before so this is something that a
pathogen like cholera could really take
advantage of and of course there was
ample transmission opportunities because
people basically transplanted their
methods of waste management that they
used in the countryside they brought
those over to the cities and you know
just didn't change
at all so in the countryside and made
sense to have cesspools and privies user
basically open pits or buried pits of
human waste there was room for it to rot
and decompose in peace but of course
doing that same thing with human waste
in a place where there's tens of
thousands of people per square kilometer
obviously created a huge sanitary crisis
because there was no sewer system or
plumbing or anything like that so
there's privies and cesspools in 19th
century Manhattan would basically just
spill their contents out into the
streets and alleys which meant that
infected stool could get into people's
Wells and also seat down into the
groundwater and about one-twelfth of the
entire city of New York was actually
covered with these privies and cesspools
know there's things that that could have
been done even back then to protect
cities like New York and London from
these repeated outbursts of cholera but
this is a time when private interest
were becoming really powerful you know
the age or the Robin robber barons etc
and so it when those commercial
interests were opposed to certain public
health strategies while they were
powerful enough to overcome any public
health efforts that were attempted to
put into place so for example in 1830
government doctors actually collected
the data that's mapped in the slide
you're seeing and it shows a pretty
clear picture to us today that collars
coming down the Hudson River and down
the Erie Canal heading straight for New
York City but they refuse to quarantine
the waterways because it was considered
disruptive to trade and these powerful
business interests were really against
it so again and again collar was able to
come into New York City through the
port's into the water waves over the
course of probably 80 years or so
and there's actually certain companies
that were making money selling collar
contaminated water the majority the
epicenter of the outbreaks in New York
often occurred in a slum called five
points which is pictured in the slide
here and this slum had actually been
built on what was once a pond that pond
had been filled up with garbage and then
the salam was built on top of it so that
water was easily contaminated with all
the leaky privies and outhouses and
cesspools on top of it however the
company that the state of New York
chartered to distribute drinking water
to the people of New York instead of
tapping upstream sources away from the
city which would have been more
expensive but cleaner they dumped there
they dug there well right in the middle
of that slum and top that that
contaminated groundwater and distribute
that to about a third of the population
of New York City now because collar was
a new disease it also really confused
the physicians of the day the the
established wisdom on how diseases
spread was a theory called me as Matt
ISM and the azmat ISM had been sort of
the medical paradigm for really
thousands of years and the idea was that
these diseases spread through smelly
airs called miasmas and these miasmas
were sort of as you know basically any
bad smell could be a miasma and these
were particularly smells that came off
of decomposing organic material so
people would try to avoid these bad
smells and miasmas and that probably
made a certain amount of sense for old
diseases like for example malaria which
is carried by mosquitoes and if you
avoided those stinky sulfurous airs
around wetlands and swamps that might
help protect you from malaria but
medical interventions based on me azmat
ism actually made cholera a lot worse
for example
in the city of London people started
installing flush toilets in the 19th
century and this is considered really
helpful because it rid people streets
and homes of these smelly heirs of human
waste these miasmas so but because they
only cared about the smells and not the
content they didn't mind dumping all of
the waste from those flush to us
directly into their drinking water
supply which was the team server and in
fact after every caller outbreak they
installed more flush toilets to dump
more of their waste into their drinking
water not less so the question is of
course what could all of this happen
again and you know this is this is the
whole reason I went into looking into
the path is to try to figure out well
could these are these conditions being
met today and what I found is that
indeed they are although on a global
scale today for example we are invading
wild habitat on a massive scale as our
farms and cities and mines and suburban
developments grow and you know that
means that we're destroying a lot of
wildlife habitat one effect of that is
that we're losing a lot of wild species
we're losing a lot of different bio
diverse species but another part of that
is that of the species who remain we are
in much more intimate contact with them
and this novel intimate contact is
allowing microbes that live inside the
bodies of animals to spill over into
human into human bodies and it's why
sixty percent of our emerging pathogens
today originate in the bodies of animals
and over seventy percent of those urging
the bodies of wild animals and one very
salient example of that is the Ebola
virus no the whole continent of Africa
has been deforested over the past 15
years or so as you can see in this
animation which shows the pace of
deforestation since 2001 in the corner
of West Africa where the Ebola epidemic
was centered I'll draw your attention to
the area between the three countries
where they met meet janae sierra leone
and liberia there was once a very
biodiverse forest that existed there
that area is called the guinea forest
region it's actually one of the most
biodiverse forest in the world at one
time what happened over the course of
the 1990s due to a very complicated
political conflict over 600,000 refugees
fled into that forest in the kanay
forest region and you can see what
happened actually from space the inset
in this slide is a satellite picture of
where those three countries me and you
can see it's mostly green the larger
picture is that same shot from satellite
but at the end of the 1990s and you can
see where that forest once was is mostly
brown now only fifteen percent of the
original forest remained because these
hundreds of thousands of refugees were
cutting down the trees to make way for
their farms and to turn into charcoal
etc so this put them into new kinds of
contact with the animals that used to
live in those forests which one of which
we now know are fruit bats which their
habitat actually stretches along the
whole area that's being defore stood in
the continent of africa and what we also
now know is when people are an intimate
contact with animals like fruit bat they
get exposed to the microbes in those
animals and this is what happened at the
end of december we ebola virus which
comes from bats most likely there was a
two-year-old child playing near a tree
where fruit bats roost did he came down
with the Ebola virus there was a single
spill or event from one bat into one
human being that two-year-old child
infected his parents and his family with
Ebola virus
infected their healthcare workers and
they infected their families and their
healthcare workers and on and on until
we had the largest Ebola epidemic in
history in which over 10,000 people have
died but these invasions of wild
habitats that are allowing new pathogens
to emerge are not just happening in poor
parts of the world they're also
happening in prosperous parts of the
world like the United States one example
is West Nile virus West Nile virus is of
course a virus of migratory birds from
Africa and those migratory birds they
land here in the United States I'm in
particular New York City by the millions
every year New York City is actually on
the Atlantic Flyway but for many years
our bird flocks lair by us we were all
protected from this virus because many
of the bird diverse bird species we had
around us actually repelled the virus
they were not good carriers of it but
what's happened over the past 25 years
is as we have destroyed more and more
avian habitat we've lost a lot of avian
habitat we've lost a lot of those
diverse bird species and what we have
left instead are a lot of opportunistic
birds species like robins and crows who
can live anywhere in any kind of sort of
degraded habitat and it just so happens
that robins and crows are excellent
carriers of West Nile virus so the fewer
diverse bird species you have and the
more robins occurs you have around the
more West Nile virus you have around and
the more likely it becomes that the
virus and birds will spill over into
humans and that's exactly what happened
in New York City in 1999 done that was
the first outbreak of West Nile virus
here in the United States and it's
basically steadily spread across the
country since then this map shows all
the counties where West Nile virus
infected birds have been found similarly
in the northeastern forest here in the
United States and the was once intact
we had a diversity of woodland creatures
that live there such as a possum and
chipmunks and all kinds of other little
creatures and they really helped control
tick populations but as we've spread our
suburbs have spread in these forests and
broken them up into little patch works
we've lost a lot of those diverse
woodland species so we don't really have
that many opossums in places like this
anymore and that makes a difference
because opossums actually can destroy
about 6,000 tix a week whereas the
animals that replace the opossums that
are the little animals that can live
everywhere in these suburbs how are
things like white-footed mice and
white-footed mice well they only destroy
about 50 tix a week so what's happened
is the fewer opossums you have and the
more white-footed mice you have the more
West Nile virus the more tix you have
and the more likely becomes that a tick
borne pathogen will spill over into
people and that's what happened in
nineteen seventy in Connecticut with an
outbreak of arthritis and children it
turned out to be so what we now know as
long disease and there's there's a whole
host of other tick-borne disease there
now I'm marching on spreading due to the
same dynamic as well and Lyme disease is
now you know a national epidemic here in
the United States we have about 300,000
people diagnosed with Lyme every year so
we're introducing pathogens into
populations through all these mechanisms
we're also providing these fantastic
amplification opportunities right now
the majority of people on this planet
actually live in rural areas they don't
live in cities but that's going to
change and that's changing really fast
by 2030 the majority of the human
population will live in cities and they
won't be cities like you know Washington
DC and Los Angeles and London they'll be
more like Freetown in Monrovia about two
billion people are expected to live in
slums where people are crowded really
close together and this this is one
reason why the
bola epidemic in West Africa was as
deadly and long-lasting as it was just
recently we've had an Ebola outbreaks in
Africa since the mid-1970s but Ebola
virus had never infected a city with
more than a few hundred thousand
inhabitants well within weeks of
emerging in the guinea forest region in
december two thousand twelve ebola virus
was able to reach three capital cities
with a combined population of nearly
three million as a result Ebola was able
to hugely explode and even spread into
multiple other countries as well but not
only people that are crowding together
offering new pathogens amplification
opportunities it's also our animals
because of rising demand for meat we
have more animals under domestication
right now than in the last 10,000 years
of domestication combined up until
nineteen sixty so a huge number of
livestock around and an increasing
number of those animals are living in
factory farms where hundreds of
thousands or millions of individuals are
crowded close together and this offers
all kinds of novel amplification
opportunities for pathogens one example
being avian influenza now avian
influenza normally lives in wild
waterfowl it doesn't really make them
very sick but when those viruses are
able to get into these factory farms of
chickens and ducks and things the virus
starts to replicate really wildly and it
evolves and mutates and ways it make it
a lot more pathogenic and so we have a
increasingly serious problem with highly
virulent forms of avian influenza and
millions of birds have been slaughtered
due to this but worse than that some of
these viruses are actually evolving in
ways that allow them to in fact humans
and of course the most salient example
of that is h5n1 which broke out in 1997
and is still making the rounds to this
day
course there's a multitude of
transmission opportunities these new
pathogens can take advantage of
including the same ones that caller
enjoyed we have about 2.6 billion people
on the planet who have no access to
modern sanitation so they are living in
the same conditions as those slum
dwellers in 19th century New York but we
also have a really new kind of sanitary
crisis and that's the crisis of
livestock waste basically we've
transplanted our old methods into of
this new scenario where we have a lot
more livestock waste to dilla in the
past farmers would use livestock waste
as fertilizer on their crops and that
worked pretty well but now we have about
7 billion tons of livestock excreta to
manage every year and it's far more than
croplands could possibly absorb so it's
right now muster is being collected in
these giant manure lagoons which is
what's pictured on the slide here
basically an easier open open untreated
pits full of animal waste and so when
rains or when there's a storm or you
know any kind of environmental change
these this material can contaminate the
rest of the environment and this those
pathogens are already starting to take
advantage of this new transmission
pathway about half of all cattle on
American feedlots are infected with Zika
toxin-producing e.coli one of these
really virulent eco lies of course I
don't make the cattle sick but we can
make people really really sick and
because cattle waste so frequently now
contaminates our food and water we have
about 70 thousand Americans coming down
with with these highly virulent forms of
E coli infections over a year now we're
ferrying these fat pathogens around in
the most efficient travel network ever
our air our flight travel network and we
have about a billion people in the air
every year and they're flying not just
into one or two airports in one or two
countries but tens of thousands of
airports with hundreds of
thousands of connections between them so
when a pathogen emerges in one part of
the world is very quickly can spread
throughout the rest of the planet thanks
to the flight travel network as the
simulation of a flu pandemic shows and
in fact our flight networks shape the
dynamics of these pandemics so much so
that you can actually predict which
cities will be infected and when based
on how many direct flights it takes to
get to the to the last infected city so
for example if you plotted all those
same cities on a map like this which
shows them in relation to their direct
flights between each other that same
simulated flu pandemic resolves into a
series of waves so these these pathogens
are emerging they're spreading we're
giving them all kinds of new
opportunities of course our defenses are
so much better today but we also live in
an era where we too have very powerful
private interests and sometimes their
interests are opposed to those of public
health of the hundred largest economies
in the world only 49 or government's 51
or corporations and an example of what
can happen when private interests are
are in conflict with the goals of public
health a good example of that is what's
happening here in the United States with
antibiotic resistant bacteria about
eighty percent of the antibiotics that
are consumed in the united states are
not consumed for medical or therapeutic
reasons they're consumed for commercial
reasons that is they're given by farmers
to livestock to help fatten them they
give them low doses in their feed and
this seems to make them grow faster so
this helps these farmers make more money
faster but it also is known to
contribute to the development of
antibiotic resistant bacteria which sick
in about two million people here kill
about 23,000 people we know that in
countries where antibiotic consumption
is regulated and where
livestock use commercial use of
antibiotics for livestock is banned that
they don't have this kind of problem
with antibiotic resistant bacteria like
we do here in the United States but
attempts to regulate the use of
antibiotics especially in livestock have
been stymied at least since the 1970s
because there are such powerful
Commission commercial interests to keep
doing it now our medical establishment
is obviously light years ahead of what
we had in the 19th century thank God but
there is also a mismatch and that I
think is just a hallmark of the fact
that a lot of these you know these are
new new diseases and new pathogens
moving in new ways and yet we continue
to apply our old approaches so a lot of
these new diseases are being you know
they're emerging out of wildlife and
livestock they're being driven forward
into human populations by social and
political factors so you know putting
that together would suggest that a
containment efforts should really
involve a variety of different
specialties a variety of different
approaches but we mostly attack these
new diseases with a biomechanical
approach which is especially in terms of
infectious diseases all about reducing
infectious disease dynamics to their
most sort of simple components and then
focusing interventions very surgically
upon those simple reduced components so
one example of that is dengi in Florida
dengue virus first broke out in florida
in 2009 hadn't been there for 70 years
and our bio medical establishment
immediately launched an attack against
the you know the the tiny little
creatures that were carrying it with
your the mosquitoes and the and the
virus itself of course and these were
surgically isolated and attacked with
chemicals and and other interventions
and it was sort of like repelling an
invasion of mosquitoes but of course
there hadn't
realness invasion in the sense that
Florida has been surrounded by countries
where dengue is endemic for a long time
the mosquitoes that carry dengi have
been present in Florida for a long time
they weren't knew what had happened in
fact was a political and social change
which is in 2008 there had been a
foreclosure crisis here in the United
States and this meant that there were a
lot of abandoned homes this was across
the country but Florida was particularly
hard-hit and South Florida was probably
one of the worst parts of the state that
were suffering this problem so because
there were all these abandoned homes it
meant there are also a lot of abandoned
swimming pools and Gardens because this
is Florida worth's tropical weather and
so when the rains came all these empty
swimming pools started to fill up with
standing water and with no one home to
let in mosquito inspectors or to even
notice that this was happening these
empty swimming pools became giant
mosquito breeding grounds and lo and
behold a year later we had this like
unprecedented outbreak of dengue in
Florida now what addressing the housing
crisis have actually helped contain this
problem in advance of it exploding as it
has I don't know because nobody tried
that but what we do know and what is
fairly clear is that the biomedical
approaches arguably failed in the sense
that dengue is now considered on its way
to becoming endemic in Florida now so
all of these conditions are being met in
various ways does that mean we will
definitely have another pandemic well I
you know this isn't Nostradamus this is
obviously this prediction is what will
happen if we don't change and I think
there are a lot of things we can do to
reduce the risk of a new pandemic for
one thing we can start to widen our
concept of microbial pathogens and where
they come from that is to link human
health with the health of our ecosystems
the health of our livestock or help
our wildlife and instead of seeing each
microbial pathogen in isolation to look
at the dynamics of infectious disease in
a much sort of larger context and that
is already starting to happen there's a
movement called one health it's been you
know signed on to you by the World
Health Organization and the Centers for
Disease Control and this is an attempt
to link up wildlife biologists and
veterinarians along with clinicians and
biomedical specialists to kind of expand
our idea of where these microbial
pathogens come from and how they they
act on him and health and our
environment so I think that's a really
promising for a step and there's a lot
that now can be done with containment
efforts to right now at the very best we
start our containment efforts against
these epidemics once they've started to
grow exponentially so on this typical
epidemic curve of cases you can see it's
after that line starts going up kind of
steeply that's when containment efforts
start because that's when you see
clusters of cases of people getting sick
and that's really in the best case
scenario in the Ebola epidemic in West
Africa we actually started a series
containment effort only after the
epidemic had already plateaued but even
in the best-case scenario we're only
starting after there's already
exponential growth in cases and we could
do a lot better now we could start you
know before that happens and squelch
these things before they start to really
spread in a serious way we don't know of
course we're a witch pandemic which
pathogens are going to cause the next
pandemic but we do know how that happens
which means we can predict where its
most likely to happen so this is a map
of hotspots of places where pathogens
are most likely to emerge these are
places where there is a lot of invasion
of wildlife habitat going on or there's
a lot of factory farming going on or
slums or a lot of
flight connections or some combination
of all of those things and while we
can't surveil the entire planet for
microbes we can do active surveillance
in these certain hotspots and that is
what's happening on a kind of ad hoc
level with various NGOs and academic
groups and also some international
agencies and the USAID for example which
is involved in this work and they're
doing things like actively looking for
microbes and how they're changing by
sampling livestock sampling wildlife
scat monitoring the health of people
sort of on the front lines like bush
meat hunters or farmers and miners and
things like that so this kind of early
detection holds a lot of promise because
you could potentially finger and find
the next pathogen that could cause a
pandemic even before it starts to cause
disease and this has already started
starting to happen a little bit starting
to happen some pathogens have already
been found in this in this fashion and
of course there's also primary you know
primary prevention we can do things like
restore wild habitat we can protect the
health of people who live in slums and
in and the animals and factory farms
these are these are the people and
animals that are going to be most
vulnerable to new diseases finally I
think we all need to become responsible
citizens in this new age of pandemics
and that means not just protecting
ourselves from disease by keeping up
with our vaccinations and avoiding
factory foods but also protecting our
friends and families by washing our
hands by not going to work when we're
sick by not sending our kids to school
when they're sick and more than anything
to remain informed and to know that each
pathogen is unique and we'll will spread
and change in different ways that we
need to be aware of because so much
the process of a pathogen turning into a
pandemic is really shaped by human
behavior in the end whether or not these
new pathogens cause pandemics is really
entirely up to us thank you so much
thank you for that presentation Sonia we
want to get right to your questions and
input so here's a reminder how to let us
know what you have to say questions etc
can be submitted via the Q&A button at
the lower left we will try to get to all
of you but if not we'll be sure to
follow up after the broadcast so I'm
going to give people a chance to to plug
in their questions to formulate
okay so here's that there are no
question so I would once again like to
thank Sonia shock or for presentation so
we have too many of final comments you'd
like to share with us well this has been
a great experience and I would be happy
to take any other questions offline I
think you all should be getting my
contact information all this whole talk
was based on a new book that's coming
out in a few months and I can give you
more information about that too if you
look me up online or use the links that
they'll that labret swill be sending out
to you but thank you all for listening I
would like to thank our sponsor leverage
for making today's educational webcast
possible lab routes comm and leading
scientific social networking site for
information visit us at www.meemtosh.com
you